happy 14th birthday Bitcoin on this day
14 years ago the pseudonymous creator of
the decentralized peer-to-peer
electronic cash system launched the
Bitcoin white paper in that paper just
nine pages long there was technical
details that would forever change the
course of history Bitcoin has grown into
the strongest Computing Network in the
world and it also is the most
disciplined Central Bank ever created as
we continue to watch 14 years later it
is absolutely breathtaking to see
hundreds of millions of people holding
the asset millions of others around the
world contributing to the mining
industry and thousands of developers
building all sorts of security and
utility applications that continue to
push the vision of peer-to-peer cash
forward one of the great benefits and
the Tailwinds to bitcoin's rise is the
absolute Insanity that continues to
happen in the traditional Financial
system we have seen undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy we have seen
a continued pursuit of surveillance
capitalism and we also have seen both
developed and developing nations use
different Financial transactions and
tools to censor and overreach on their
citizens at the end of the day Satoshi
Nakamoto put together a paper and put it
out to the world but that paper was only
created after much of the code for
Bitcoin was already written Bitcoin was
pushed Live January 3rd 2009 and no one
paid attention other than a small group
of folks who are interested in
cryptography but here we are less than
15 years later and Bitcoin has shook the
world bitcoin's rise will be studied by
historians for decades and centuries to
come it continues to be exactly what the
Creator wanted it to become
decentralized peer-to-peer electronic
cash happy birthday Bitcoin and thank
you to every single one of you who's
watching this you all are contributing
to the rise of Bitcoin to the build out
of the network and to the education of
millions and millions of people around
the world in your unique way Satoshi
sacrificed himself by simply creating a
piece of technology open sourcing it and
walking away my hope for myself and each
of you is that we can look back at our
contributions to bitcoin and we can say
to ourselves
that was fun that was effective and I'm
glad that I spent my time money and
energy pushing forward towards a brand
new world a world that I want to live in
in a world that I want my children and
grandchildren to live in as well